nous en savons désormais beaucoup plus à
propos du camp de Dora mitelbao en
Allemagne là où quelques 20000 déportés
dont bon nombre de Français ont trouvé
la mort durant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale Dora là où le régime nazi
concevait en secret vous venez de le
voir ces fusées V1 et V2 l'occasion pour
nous maintenant d'évoquer le martyre à
travers ce film vécu par les victimes du
système concentrationnaire nazi avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de
débadoc Laurent Thierry pour commencer
euh bienvenue vous êtes historien chargé
de recherche à la Fondation de la
Résistance on vous a vu bien sûr dans ce
film et pour cause vous avez dirigé cet
imposant ouvrage Le livre des 9000
déportés de France à mitelbao Dora cand
de concentration et d'extermination par
le travail c'est un ouvrage publié au
cherchemidi vous allez nous en parter en
en parler c'est un un formidable travail
mémoriel que vous avez réalisé pas tout
seul d'ailleurs
62 rédacteurs vous ont accompagné des
bénévoles également pour réaliser cet
ouvrage qui est uniqueass hein mais vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi dans un
instant et ce livre ce travail mémoriel
et bien c'est vous qui l'avez préfacé
Aurélie felipetti trois de vos aïeux
sont en effet passés par ce camp dont
votre grand-père un seul un seul en
reviendra l'un de vos grands oncles vous
nous en direz plus évidemment dans un
instant euh rappelons tout de même que
vous êtes ancien ministre de la Culture
et vous êtes aujourd'hui la directrice
des affaires culturelles à la mairie de
Paris et puis enfin Johann chapouto est
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes historien
auteur spécialiste du nazisme et de
l'Allemagne professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université Paris
Sorbonne on vous doit entre autres
nombreux ouvrages celui-ci comprendre le
nazisme un ouvrage disponible aux
éditions talangier Laurent Thierry donc
euh on a on vous a vu dans ce
documentaire euh et on a surtout vu et
et compris avec ce film le travail
mémoriel que vous avez réalisé grâce à à
cet ouvrage que j'ai amené avec moi en
plateau il est très volumineux euh avec
d'ailleurs euh en couverture euh des
dessins réalisés par euh euh des
déportés de oui oui un ancien déporté
hein qui s'appelait Léon de l'arbre qui
était lui-même déporté résistant au
candora alors ce projet c'est d'abord la
volonté la volonté des déporter
eux-mêmes des des survivants à la fin
des années 90 de de pouvoir rendre
hommage identifier d'abord rendre
hommage à tous les déportés de France
qui qui sont passés par ce camp et bien
entendu à à leurs victimes c'est un long
projet de recherche un 15 années de de
travail dans les archives parce que
c'est un projet mémoriel mais c'est
aussi un projet scientifique hein à
partir des archives du camp on a la
chance d'avoir énormément de documents
qui ont qui ont été conservés et
conservver pour les archives allemandes
tout à faitamp tout à fait les archives
produites du temps de de fonctionnement
du camp on a on a toute une
administration à l'intérieur de ces camp
je pense que on y reviendra un fichage
systématique de ces déportés qui nous a
permis d'aller chercher les informations
d'identifier et donc déécrire des
histoires le de la manière la plus
précise précise possible alors vous le
disiez c'est c'est un travail de deun
travail collectif euh c'est avant tout
l'engagement de de de près de 70
bénévoles essentiellement des
enseignants mais des historiens aussi
universitaires hein qui ont euh qui à
partir de ces données collecté pendant
ces années ont écrit ces histoires de
vie euh une par une près de près de 9000
vies hein qui sont qui sont très très
détaillées et puis c'est c'est enfin le
le l'engagement d'un d'un éditeur hein
qui a euh qui a pris l'engagement de
réaliser cet ouvrage on va le reciter
c'est le Cher m ou le Cher midi et et
Philippe et cet éditeur a entièrement
financé ce travail c'est toutit et il il
est même allé plus loin puisque il a
décidé de de de d'éditer 9000
exemplaires pour 9000 déportés qui sont
numérotés et que aujourd'hui nous
offrons à chaque famille que nous
pouvons identifier à chaque famille de
de descendants aurélie a pu euh euh
recevoir cet exemplaire euh lors de la
cérémonie que nous avions organisé
disait à Montluc à Lyon en 2021 alors
vous l'avez reçu est ce qui est
formidable finalement à travers ce
travail mémoriel c'est ce que ce travail
vous a permis d'en savoir beaucoup plus
sur vos aïeux deux grands oncles et
votre grand-père du côté de votre votre
père et vous en avez appris vous avez
appris leur parcours leur histoire en
grande partie grâce à ce travail
mémoriel oui parce que c'est vrai que le
camp de Dora il n'est pas connu en fait
dans dans dans ce qu'on apprend aussi
bien dans les familles qu'à l'école
c'est vrai que moi j'avais entendu ce
nom mais ce nom en plus en soit Dora
déjà c'est très c'est c'est c'est un nom
de femme en fait c'est pas du tout un
nom de femme hein c'est c'est un
acronyme en allemand mais ça ressemble à
un nom de femme c'est c'est presque des
sonorités douces et et moi je me
souviens que quand j'avais j'ai entendu
parler de Dora pour la première fois je
je comprenais pas j'arrivais pas
associer ça avec un un camp de
concentration c'est vous associer
d'ailleurs dans votre imaginaire je
crois d' avantage à une un personnage de
dessin animé qui s'appelait Dora mais
oui parce que c'est vrai que c'est c'est
très étonnant et et en fait je ne je
connaissais pas du tout les spécificités
de ce camp moi je je connaissais le
parcours de mon grand-père et de ses
frères c'est-à-dire que ils étaient
passé par mes le schutov en Alsace puis
buckenwald et de buckenwald ils avaient
été donc dans ce camp que je considérais
comme une annexe de bukenwald et puis
mon grand-père lui a fait la les marches
de la mort il est mort à Bergen donc au
moment de la libération du camp mais
donc ce que j'ai appris notamment sur
les V1 et les V2 qui étaiit fabriqués
dans ces galeries souterraines qui
étaient des des galeries de mines et et
mon grand-père était mineur et ses
frères étaient mineurs donc je pense que
c'est aussi pour ça qu'ils ont été
sélectionnés pour travailler dans dans
ces galeries ce que j'ai appris et qu'on
voit dans le documentaire est vraiment
est vraiment fascinant parce que c'était
un lieu qui était en fait complètement
stratégique et crucial pour le régime
nazi ce qui donne un relief particulier
à ce qui était votre travail c'est
effectivement ce qui était la
spécificité de ce camp oui qui
justifiait qu'on en a très peu parlé par
la suite parce que tout ça était secret
défense en tout cas du côté américain
hein qui a exfiltrer un certain nombre
de euh de savants de technicienement par
la suite hein la France aussi d'ailleurs
voilà et ça c'est ce qui explique qu'on
en savait très très peu sur ce camp et
j'imagine c'est ce qui a justifié votre
votre travail oui c'était c'était une
volonté des des familles des déportés
justement de de sortir de de l'oubli ce
ce camp il faut il faut pas oublier que
dès dès la sortie de la guerre il y a
une véritable chape de plomb qui est qui
est imposée sur l'histoire de de ce lieu
et une volonté mais véritablement une
volonté politique notamment de la part
des des Américains de de de cacher de de
rendre inaccessibles les archives qui
concernent ce camp évidemment d'empêcher
que les scientifiques qui ont été on le
voit dans le documentaire qui ont été
ensuite recrutés par les différentes
puissances alliés puissent témoigner des
crimes qu'ils avaient non seulement pu
constater eux-mêmes mais auquel ils
étaient ils étaient liés liés
directement donc on a cette cette
mémoire qui a été empêché pendant
pendant des années malgré le le travail
des des amicales et des anciens déportés
notamment l'Amicale de Roy rich qui a
été la principale amicale qui réunissait
ces famille et ses anciens déportés
c'est c'est elle qui qui qui portera et
qui décidera de de réaliser ce
dictionnaire biographique Dora melbo il
faut peut-être resituer ce qui a été ce
camp je crois que c'est il a deux
spécificités ce camp au-delà de ce qu'on
a appris dans ce documentaire évidemment
on y fabriquait les V1 les V2 hein et ce
qui explique le secret qui entouré par
la suite ce ce camp c'était le je crois
le 13e et et dernier camp grand camp de
concentration mis en place par par les
Allemands et ça a été aussi le plus
meurtrier est-ce qu'est-ce qu'on peut
dire de plus sur ce camp pour mieux
comprendre de quel camp de concentration
nous sommes en train de parler dans dans
cette émission ESS peut-être de brosser
un panorama du système concentrationn
Naas j'aimerais d'AB d'abord revenir sur
ce que disait tout à l'heure on a
d'ailleurs une carte oui mais à propos
du nom de Dora les nom les noms des
camps de concentration sont souvent
bechwiishtigen comme on dit en allemand
souvent doux et et agréable bchenenwald
par exemple c'est la forêt des c'est la
forêt des êtres zaxenhausen c'est un
toponyme très courant bergenbsen c'est
un lieu bucolique et et Dora
effectivement il y a ce jeu sur
l'acronyme et sur le prénom de femme
pour c'est c'est c'est thématique et
structurelle chez les nazis hein de de
de de d'adoucir les choses par la
toponymie et par et par les noms et puis
pour ce qui est du du système
concentrationnire eu c'est à l'origine
un un système de de répression
terroriste he ouvertement terroriste
c'est une terreur policière
administrative qui est qui est mise en
branle à partir de l'ordonnance du
d'exception du 28 février 1933 qui au
fond déjudiciarise les procédures de
répression hein les juges sont écartés
et désormais c'est la police qui sur
acte administratif vous incarcère c'est
des choses qu'on connaît en France aussi
he depuis les différents états d'urgence
sans contrôle du juge et les lieux de
détention ne sont plus des lieux de
détention mais de rétention
administrative he la détention c'est la
prison la rétention c'est les camps et
les camps ne sont pas secret du tout
hein c'est publique c'est même publicisé
ça montre la volonté du gouvernement de
relèvement ou de réarmement national
comme on disait déjà à l'époque de
réprimer les les éléments antinationaux
et c'est un système concentrationnaire
qui s'adresse d'abord aux Allemands il y
a pas de Juifs ni de juifs allemands
d'ailleurs dans les camps de
concentration parce que ce sont des
lieux de rééducation he Tao zxenhausen
benval et cetera Daro qui ou dascho hein
pour moi qui qui parle moins bien
allemand que vous y chaputo c'est le
premier camp qui est vu le jour en
Allemagne 1933 mais il y a 110 camps qui
sont ont été établis en Allemagne dès
1933 dès la prise du pouvoir en AZ alors
en Allemagne et au-delà des frontières
allemandes dans tout territoire qui est
annexé la première chose que font les
nazis c'est d'envoyer des unités de la
police et de la SS rafler des gens et
d'ouvrir un camp Mausen en Autriche
quand l'Autriche est annexé euh euh
Auschwitz en Silésie le schutov en Mosel
et en Alsace Mosel annexé et cetera donc
tout ça est très cohérent et la la
comment dire la la fonctionnalité des
camps change à partir de la seconde
guerre du du début de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale on accueille toujours des
Allemands à des fins de rééducation on
accueille désormais des Juifs ça c'est
depuis la nuit de Cristal he il y un
coup de pression violent sur la
communauté juive pour les forcer à
partir donc on incarcère 30000 juifs
dans leséc de concentration pour la
première fois en 1938 fin 38 et à partir
de 39 les camps sont voués à l'accueil
de tous les ennemis du Reich définis
comme ennemis du rage de toute l'Europe
et ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
le système des camp devient à la fois
hyper fonctionnalisé en dans la
direction de la production économique ce
sont des lieux qui doivent être
rentables performants ce sont des
concepts nazis hein par exemp par
exemple à Auschwitz le le
complexe'appelle la zone d'intérêt si
vous voulez intérêt économique hein et
par ailleurs ça devient un lieu
totalement dysfonctionnel au fur et à
mesure de la dégradation de la situation
militaire allemande et des de la faible
comment dire du faible approvisionnement
que l'on donne au camp ça devient des
mourroirs à ciel ouvert on va voir une
carte pour situer ce qui était ces ces
camps regardez cette cette carte là vous
avez que les principaux camp à la fois
camp de concentration qui figurent noir
nous avons situé bien sûr Dora mitelbao
sur cette carte en plus gras c'est au
nord-ouest de burenval burenval qui
était le le camp dont dépendait dans un
premier temps
Dora puis ensuite Dora mitelbao a eu sa
propre autonomie on l'a dit tout à
l'heure puis en rouge hein regardez sur
cette carte ce sont les les six C de la
mort six camp d'extermination qui étai
tous situés en Pologne on le voit sur
sur cette carte on reviendra sur ce
système concentrationnire dans dans un
instant simplement pour bien comprendre
pourquoi Dora mitelbao était le dernier
grand camp de concentration mis en place
par les les nazis et pourquoi a-t-il été
le plus meurtrier de tous les camp en
tout cas c'est c'est ce qui est dit sur
ce fameux camp alors sur le caractère
meurtrier je pense que tu pourras plus
intervenir mais en l'occurrence c'est un
un camp qui est affecté dès le départ à
la production économique à une
production économique stratégique en
l'occurrence d'armement de pointe les
fameuses
les fameuses armes de de de je sais plus
comment on dit en français fa gtong va
de de je vous aider là de représaille
merci avec avec d'ailleurs la Fondation
la création d'une division de la vafan
SS voué à cela he la la la division de
représaille la FAO division dirigé par H
scamler dont on reparlera c'est un type
très très important et c'est un lieu
secret puisque c'est une production
stratégique qui doit être protégée hein
ça se fait en lien avec le ministère de
l'armement de Chep vu la l'intensité de
la campagne aérienne britannique et
américaine contre l'Allemagne il faut
enterrer les les usines stratégiques
donc on le fait à Dora dans des systèmes
de tunnel invivables et on le fait
également dans les Alpes Hans camler lui
aussi est chargé de créer des des des
usines souterraines dans les montagnes
des Alpes dans la fameuse forteresse
alpine notamment à ebze pour la
production de Messer Schmid avion de
pointe puisque c'est les premiers avions
àaction pourquoi ce camp était-il le
plus meurtrier de tous les camps de
concentration allemand la spécificité de
Dora je crois et c'est un c'est un un
des rares exemples dans l'histoire du
système concentrationnaire parce que à
la fois ce camp est spécifique mais il
s'intègre évidemment dans dans dans ce
système avec évidemment des interactions
entre ces camps des échanges entre ces
camps évidemment mais la particularité
c'est d'abord qu'il n'y a pas de camp
c'est-à-dire que pendant les les 8
premiers mois d'existence de ce lieu les
lieux les déportés sont directement
logés doivent travailler à l'intérieur
de ces galeries froides et humides et là
c'est la responsabilité d' scamler qui
donne évidemment la pri priorité à
l'installation de cette usine à
n'importe quel prix et au prix de la
mort de près de 6000 déportés dans les 8
premiers mois d'existence de ce lieu et
c'est seulement une fois que l'usine de
production des fusées commencera à
démarrer au début 1944 que camler
donnera enfin l'autorisation de
construire un camp de baraque tel qu'on
peut l'imaginer tel qu'on le voit on
voit sur les images de de la Libération
on va écouter avant de de revenir vers
vous Aurélie philippiti l'un des des
détenus hein qui a été dans dans dans ce
quand il s'agit de Pierre Marc et qui
était bien entendu dans le film que nous
avons vu il y a un instant on était
entre nous et puis on avait le moral on
disait on va ils vont ils vont nous
envoyer en Allemagne on va aller
travailler comme les comme les ho de
l'époque quoi on va aller travailler en
usine on se doutait vraiment pas du tout
d'ailleurs en France personne ne
connaissait l'existence des qu
concentration et ça c'est ça s'est
découvert après la guerre mais pendant
la guerre personne n' causait personne
n'était au courant
trois anciens déportés dont Pierre
mararc ont témoigné dans dans ce film
malheureusement l'un d'entre eux est est
décédé hein depuis le ce tournage on le
dit jamais assez mais il est encore
temps de recueillir ces ces témoignages
parce que ces personnes sont encore
vivantes et peuvent encore
transmettre cette mémoire vos aïeux
avaient laissé tout de même des des
traces de ce passage av un temps soit
peu raconter ce qu' a été leur martyre
justement à l'occasion de ce passage
leur AR station puis c'est arrivé à à
Dora mitelbao euh non il y a a on a
aucune trace en fait de celui qui est
revenu sur les trois en fait n'en a
jamais parlé après c'était le plus jeune
des trois frères c'était le plus jeune
ouais il était il était né en 1911 et il
a été alors ils ont été arrêtés tous les
trois en même temps le même jour euh
février 1944 et ils ont été ils avaient
trois numéros successifs d'ailleursah
tout ça j'ai retrouvé en fait c'est ça
qui est fascinant dans le travail
d'archive dans le travail des historiens
c'est que moi j'ai j'avais entendu des
récits dans ma famille qui étaient des
récits AUAU sur l'arrestation sur leur
parcours et en fait avec le le le
travail de Laurent Tiry et des
historiens qui qui ont réalisé ce livre
je me suis rendu compte que tout ce que
j'avais entendu en fait était vrai mais
il y avait des preuv il y avait des
papiers il y avait des traces et donc ça
c'est très émouvant de retrouver dans
les archives
bah par exemple les fiches qui donnent
l'arrivée au camp et puis ils sont
interrogés et donc on dit ben voilà mon
grand-père il avait quatre enfants donc
il donne les les âges des enfants et et
donc mon père ben voilà il avait il
avait 6 ans quoi en fait donc quand
c'est c'est ça c'est vraiment on voit la
richesse de l'histoire et ce côté
bouleversant qu'on voit très bien dans
le documentaire à travers cette dame qui
a la lettre de son père qui témoigne qui
témoigne sur ses conditions de vie et de
travail dans dans ce camp et et donc il
y a très peu de choses parce que il y a
il n'en est resté quasiment aucune trace
et moi j'avais juste connaissance de
l'existence du camp avant le travail de
Laurent par une photo qui était un peu
la photo qui était voilà dans la famille
où où on voyait donc mon grand-père et
ces deux frères et puis c'était pour
l'un d'entre eux c'était marqué disparu
à Dora et donc que j'avais que ça en
fait hein et et finalement j'ai appris
que donc les trois ont été ont fait
vraiment le même parcours au même moment
ils se sont suivis donc il y en a un qui
est mort en mars 1944 à Dora
et ce qu'il faut peut-être préciser
c'est que ce sont les 9000 déportés de
France dont vous parlez dans votre dans
votre ouvrage mais 700 d'entre eux
étaient d'origine étrangère et 60
d'entre eux étaient d'origine italienne
et c'était le cas de de vos aïux car ils
étaient italiens c'était des résistant
antifascistes oui c'est ça et en fait
moi ça m'a toujours fasciné ça parce que
ils étaient italiens mais ils étaient
ils vivaient en France et ils
travaillaient en France et ils ont été
arrêtés comme résistants parce qu'ils
ont été sans doute enfin on a longtemps
cru qu'ils avaient été dénoncés par des
gens malintentionnés en fait ils ont
sans doute été identifiés par les les en
fait les miliciens anti les miliciens
fascistes euh de l'allégation fasciste
mussolinienne qui était à ce moment-là
au Luxembourg et donc la moiselle
annexée c'était et c'était sans doute
par les fascistes italiens qu's ont été
arrêtés par les nazis allemands au fond
de la mine en France et ensuite ils ont
été enfin quand mon grand-père et mon
grand-père est en en avril 1945 sur la
liste de des des détenus qui sont
trouvés qui étit encore vivant le 20
avril
19445 au moment de de de la libérration
duamp de Bergen Belsen et il est inscrit
dans la liste des déportés français
alors qu'en fait il est italien et je
trouve je trouve voilà c'est c'est une
très belle histoire européenne pour pour
montrer que voilà ces gens se sont
battus pour la liberté notre liberté à
tous notre liberté à tous les Européens
et même t les tous les tous les humains
et vous disiez c'est sans doute parce
qu'ils avaient été mineurs ils ont été
transférés de dans ce camp hein pour les
raisons que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est le cas il y avait déjà un
tri qui était fait par les Allemands on
va laisser après Johan chapouto en
parler mais à bourenvall il y avait
véritablement une sélection des détenus
hein certains des des ingénieurs et des
scientifiques notamment vererner
vonbrown viennent à bourenval et font
une sorte de comme une sorte de marché
marché pour sélectionner certaines
professions alors dans les premiers mois
on prend un peu un peu tout le monde
parce que il s'agit de d'aménager des
galeries de creuser des galeries d'ù là
l'intérêt d'avoir des mineurs évidemment
ces gens qui ont ses compétences et puis
une fois que l'usine va fonctionner on
va essayer de de sélectionner des des
électriciens des serruriers des gens
gens qui ont des compétences propres des
gens qui travaillaient dans les
télécommunications voir des des
ingénieurs qui travaillaient eux-mêmes
dans dans des bureaux d'études en France
et on va les spécifiquement les dirigés
les diriger vers ce camp il y a il y a
tout ce travail sans dilon he sur
l'organisation de ces camps par le le le
régime nazi je vais citer un chiffre en
tout cas une une fourchette parce que
c'est celle dont je dispose il y aurait
eu
42500 quand euh allemand et nazi
d'installer durant la la Seconde Guerre
mondiale c'est un chiffre issu du du
Mémorial de la choix de de Washington
j'ai vu le chiffre de 44000 également
donc d' d'où cette idée de parler d'une
d'une fourchette ce qu'on voudrait
comprendre c'est comment on distingue
ces camps du côté nazi à travers les
personnes qu'on peut y trouver les
détenus euh et et la vocation conséquent
est-ce qu'on peut faire des distinctions
pour essayer de bien comprendre alors
déjà un petit point peut-être de de
vocabulaire ou de
terminologie les camp de concentration
existe administrativement en tant que
tel avec ce noml concentration slaga KL
ou KZ l'abréviation par contre les camps
d'extermination n'existent pas alors je
suis pas négationniste quand je dis ça
je dis juste que c'est une terminologie
qui éé crée à nurbert pour des raisons
de comment dire de de lecture hein de
classification de typologie mais déjà
les les ce ne sont pas des camps
d'extermination dans la mesure o on ne
campe pas quand on arrive dans un centre
de mise à mort on est tué en 1 heure 1
heure3 ce ne sont pas des camps de
travail ce ne sont pas des camps où on
réside on ne campe pas he littéralement
donc ça trèblina RNO belchck Sobibor
birkeno ne sont pas des CS d'ailleurs
les nazis appellent ça SS Z commando
généralement hein commando spécial ce
qui veut rien dire mais c'est encore une
fois une une volonté terminologique donc
euh les ce qu'on appelle les camps ce
sont les camps de concentration et en
l'occurrence les stamlager les camps
Souch ou les camps sources qui ont
énormément parfois des centaines de de
de de House and commando c'est-à-dire
des des petits camps de travail qui euh
sont affectés euh à une mine à une forêt
à un ravin à une rivière et cetera d'où
la prolifération métastatique au fond
hein de cette nébuleuse de des camps
mais en l'occurrence il y a très peu de
camps principaux camps de concentration
principaux bchenenval en fait partie et
Dora en fera partie Infiné in extrémist
au fond dans la liste euh mais euh c'est
bien à distinguer de ce que l'historien
raou Hilberg très pertinemment a appelé
dès les années 80 les centre de mise à
mort parce que de fait on y vient pour
être tué ni pour travailler ni pour
camper ni pour eu en revanche c'est
l'extermination par le
travail qui est symbolisé aussi par le
le film que nous venons de voir c'est
très important moi j'ai travaillé sur le
le travail justement la conception na
naz du travail dans dans libre d'obéir
et j'ai montré que les nazis
s'inscrivent parfaitement dans une et
c'est le profil de Hans camler le montre
très bien dans un dans une logique au
fond qui est celle du capitalisme
contemporain et qui est celui de la
ressource humaine he comme on dit
aujourd'hui avec cette expression atroce
que les nazis appellent ressources
humaines ou Mantion matéial matériaux
humain qui qui est considéré comme un
fond d'énergie dans lequel on va puiser
jusqu'à l'épuisement c'est-à-dire que on
on considère que le le la matière
humaine la biomasse doit être épuisé
jusqu'à la fin avec d'ailleurs aucune
nécessité de respecter les frais fixes
habituels hein typiquement l'hébergement
hein ou la nourriture puisque le
turnover comme on dit aujourd'hui est
tel avec l'arrivée le flux massif
d'arrivée que on peut laisser mourir en
masse sans comment dire augmenter les
frais fixes et donc en augmentant la
plusvalue si vous voulez hein et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est pratiqué
dans les camp de concent tion à ceci
près que on prend soin quand même
parfois de certains types de
travailleurs qui sont des travailleurs
spécialisés et qui sont d'ailleurs tout
à fait répertorié dans un système
informatique ou pré-informatique avec
des cartes perforé mécaniques
technologie IBM hein puisque IBM a
beaucoup profiter de sa collaboration
avec les nazis comme à peu près toutes
les grandes compagnies américaines et
allemandes avec une technologie qui la
technologie hollerit qui sont des cartes
perforées de système préinformatique qui
permettaiit de de localiser de spécifier
très bien les spécialités des différents
travailleurs qui étaient ensuite
affectés à tout nouveau camp par exemple
quand on cré ma Housen en 38 on fait
venir des charpentiers des plombiers des
maçons de tel et tel endroit qui sont
répertoriés dans les technologies IBM
deux choses pour compléter ce que disait
Johann il n'y a pas d'étanchéité entre
ces camp et ces systèmes le le rapport à
l'économie cette productivité qui va
être au cœur du fonctionnement de San à
partir de 1943 va obliger laass à revoir
sa stratégie notamment dans le cadre de
extermination et la sélection à
l'arrivée dans ces dans ces centres de
mise à mort et dans ces camps de
concentration comme comme a achwitz qui
a les deux statutes va permettre de de
de récupérer une main d'œuvre juive
potentiellement utilisable et d'être
transféré dans ces concentration pour
être utilisé ce qui fait que à partir de
l'été 1944 on va voir aussi une
population juive arrivé au camp d'ora
pour être affecté à des nouveaux
chantiers extérieurs de creusement
d'installation d'usine et dernier point
ce qui leur permettait peut-être
peut-être d'échapper à la mort au bout
du compte
oui tempora temp c'était temporaire
parce que de toute façon il avait des
des durées de de vie très courte hein
comme c'est dit dans le reportage dans
certains ce qui renvoie cette cette
question de d'une mort lente une mort
liée au travail forcé aux conditions de
détention à la violence qui est
permanente aussi on en a pas parlé mais
tout l'encadrement est structuré par par
cette violence confié souvent à des des
détenus de droit commun des Allemands
qui étaient parfois on sait aujourd'hui
dans les prisons allemandes depuis même
bien avant l'arrivée du du nazisme
dernier point sur lequel je voulais
insister c'est c'est la manière dont
dont va se structurer ce rapport à la
productivité de ces détenus tout ça est
centralisé à Berlin comme le disait
Johann avec un système un système de
fichage mais cela va très loin au au
niveau à l'intérieur de ces camp et Dora
on est un petit peu l'archétype comment
est-ce que l'on va mettre en place un
système très pernicieux en offrant
certains privilèges à certains détenus
pour augmenter cette cette productivité
tout ça relève de de directives qui sont
envoyé de Berlin aussi évidemment
sanctionné on a on parle dans le
documentaire de de la question des de la
répression des sabotages et des les
pandaisons à partir de l'été 1944 des
directives sont envoyées à tous les
commandants de camp donc y compris à
Dora pour organiser les pandaisons pour
que les pandaisons de saboteurs soient
visiblebl de l'ensemble des détenus
évidemment pour les inciter à ne pas
commettre d'autres sabotages c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est organisé
préparé et inséré et et on le voit au
travers des des archives qui
heureusement on a on a la chance de
pouvoir utiliser et et et et consulter
aujourd'hui on voit comment se met se
met en place ce mécanisme à l'intérieur
de ces camp et qui concerne chacun idu
et ça renvoie ce qu' ce qu' et l'horreur
de ce système concentrationnaire nazi je
vais citer euh euh quelques mots que
vous avez écrit dans cette préface à
propos de ce quand vous dites cette
histoire est la mienne parce que c'est
celle de ma famille c'est la nôtre à
nous tous qui vivons après eux habités
de questionnement hantés par leurs
fantômes nous en sommes les dépositaires
or que pouvons-nous transmettre si nous
n'en savons rien euh sur sur ce travail
mémoriel effectué par laurentierry et
tous ceux qui ont travaillé avec vous
pourquoi est-il aussi nécessaire
aujourd'hui à vos yeux vous étiez
directement concerné au même titre que
toutes les autres familles de déporté et
qui sont passés par par Dora qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire sur sur tout
l'intérêt de ce travail mémoriel
aujourd'hui en 2024 sur moi ce qui me
frappe quand je lis parce que j'ai
beaucoup lu des des livres soit
d'historiens soit des témoignages des
réers évidemment Primo Lévi par exemple
enfin mais à chaque fois il y a C cette
obsession c'est évidemment ces gens
comme le disent monsieur ce témoin
pourquoi moi j'ai survécu et pas les
autres en fait le le sens qu'il donne à
ça c'est toujours témoigner raconter
pour que cela n'arrive plus jamais c'est
c'est ce que dit Primo Levi d d dès les
premières pages il ne faut plus jamais
que ça puisse se produire or ça s'est
produit et il y a pas si longtemps ce
qui veut dire que ça peut un jour
recommencer sous une autre forme et et
évidemment raconter cette
histoire essayer d'en faire sentir toute
la douleur toute l'horreur et et tout
l'aspect inommable et incommunicable
mais on essaie de s'approcher de ça et
bien ça ça permet quand même de se dire
faisons attention et et soyons
extrêmement vigilant pour que jamais ça
ne puisse se reproduire ça s'est passé
dans un pays qui était qui était
l'Allemagne qui était un pays tout à
fait développé cultivé enfin voilà qui
était à la pointe de la science on le
voit avec des personnages comme ce van
Brown qui est une horreur qui est un
nazi et qui est en même temps un immense
scientifique qui d'ailleurs récupéré par
les Américains après la guerre ça aussi
c'est une histoire terrible donc des
gens comme ça ont été capables de
participer à la pire barbarie sans doute
l'une des pires barbaries de l'histoire
donc c'est ça la leçon c'est ça c'est ça
la leçon qu'il faut en tirer et c'est
pour ça que ce travail il est
indispensable et et on va rappeler qu'il
n'y a pas que les Américains qu' filtrer
des des des ingénieurs des savants nazis
he nous aussi français nous avons
exfiltré entre 4000 et 5000 de ces
savants ingénieurs techniciens et qui
ont largement contribué ça a été dit
dans ce documentaire à
réarmer la France he à travers
l'industrie balistique la fusée Arian et
aux États-Unis c'était bien sûr
concernant V brand
les programmes Mercury et et Apollo moi
je c'est unique ce travail qui a été
réalisé sur sur les camps de dit de
concentration parce que il y a eu le le
il y a eu beaucoup de travaux autour des
des des camps d'extermination et le et
et ce qui a
été la la
oui tout ce tout le travail autour de de
la choix qui a été réalisé pour
j'aimerais embrayer sur ce que disait
auréliie PHPP c'est très important ça
s'est produit ça peut se reproduire
d'autant plus plus que au fond les
fondamentaux qui ont permis cette
horreur sont toujours là finalement
après 1945 on l'avait vu dans le débat
documentaire qu'on avait fait sur la
dénazification qui a été inexistante he
en RFA on est passé tout de suite à une
configuration de guerre froide donc on a
plus lutter contre les nazis puisqu'on
avait de fait besoin des nazis pour
combattre le communisme vous parliez des
ingénieurs et techniciens du programme
Arian qui ont été transférés en France
mais il faut parler aussi des milliers
de vafanesss qui ont été recrutés par la
Légion étrangère française de telle
sorte que le champ de la légion
aujourd'hui c'est le champ de la vafnss
he au passage encore aujourd'hui hein
euh et euh ça c'est visible si vous
voulez au profil et au destin d'un type
comme Hans camler donc le grand
ingénieur en chef docteur ingénieur he
architecte et responsable au sein de
l'Office central de l'économie de
l'administration de tout ce qui est
construction et qu'on a vu hein dans ce
film bien sûr Hans camler il est tout à
fait représentatif d'une élite on va
dire technocratico managériale très bien
formé donc il est ingénieur docteur des
universités université technique et
c'est quelqu'un qui fonctionne dans un
univers mental qui est le nôtre en fait
hein performance rentabilité efficacité
utilitarisme dans la manière de traiter
la main d'œuvre le nazisme est un
extractivisme hein c'est ça dévaste tout
et ça dévaste également les individus
qui sont encore une fois assignés au
simple rôle de fond d'énergie dans
lequel on va puiser on extrait de la
valeur ajoutée jusqu'à la mort bon et
par ailleurs les comment dire les
coordonnées mentales sont celles de
l'efficacité de la productivité de de la
performance et Hans camler ce qui est
très intéressant c'est qu'il est censé
sêt suicid le 9 mai 45 les sources sur
àonond en témoignage disant que oui oui
on l'a bien vu se flinguer et cetera
sauf que on le retrouve dans des
documents américains jusqu'en novembre
1945 et qu'il est fort possible c'était
son projet d'ailleurs hein de partir
avec ses dossiers et ses fichiers et
seses son carnet d'adresse pour se
vendre aux Américains il est possible
qu'il était exfiltré aux États-Unis en
tout cas il ne s'est pas suicidé hein au
printemps 45 contrairement à ce que les
sources nazis et puis ensuite les
jugements judiciaires wouest allemands
il fait partie de ces gens qu'on a
au-delà des scientifiques et des
techniciens on a utilisé des managers
des technocrates pour réarmer encore une
fois l'Occident face au communisme ce
travail ça sera la toute fin vraiment
que vous avez réalisé autour de de ce
camp de d'Oran mitelbao il est unique
concernant les les camps de
concentration mis en place par les
Allemands alors il y a eu un certain
nombre de monographies he sur l'histoire
des camp là on est vraiment sur une
approche individu par individu mais mais
en même temps cette histoire qui rend
hommage au parcours de ces gens qui qui
permet d'incarner aussi hein ce le le
parcours de de de de ces gens qui
étaient des gens engagés et qui ont qui
ont souffert à l'intérieur de de de ce
système il permet aussi de de mieux
comprendre ce ce le fonctionnement des
camps et nous il nous éclaire aussi sur
sur l'histoire de C concentration et
tous ceux qui souhaitent consulter ce
ces trouvages peuvent le faire il faut
qu'ils se rendent à la Fondation de la
Résistance par exemple oui ouou ou dans
toutes les librairies ou dans toutes les
librairies bien entendu un grand merci
vraiment merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat dooc
aujourd'hui vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtagdbat dooc bien entendu nous les
attendons vous serz là j'imagine pour
réagir à ce que seront ses réactions
merci à Selma sali Sarah Eline qui m'ont
aidé à préparer cette émission prochain
rendez-vous avec des Badoc ça sera la
même place la même heure et bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très
[Musique]
bientôt
ye